yoth 27 oui êtes vous prêt à pénétrer
dans une maison hantée moi pas du tout
aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur
paranormal voilà pour bien terminer
l'année un petit jeu déjà laisse-moi
cliquez sur place de plus loin du goca
ce moment d'un troc homme s'était pris
pour quitter prix pour squeeze et ben tu
as bien raison sûrement plus intéressant
que lui plaît c'est parti ça commence
donc on est vendredi à 23h et ce mec dit
que sa maison est hantée et les
sculpteurs donc ça touche vous voyez
c'est important extrêmement effrayant
sur ses sculptures 1 et après se plaint
que les maisons hantées le court il veut
prouver que c'est réel et qui essaie pas
de devenir un célèbre sur internet
et moi je te crois je te crois voilà on
s'arrête là c'est bon soin de la vidéo
ça y est c'est parti
et ben écoute on y va on y va au film au
film on attend que j'ai une petite
lumière aussi in this light va allumer
la télé ou pas non bon mc cann est non
plus aux high m'a donné des frissons ce
bruit c'était horrible at elle
impressionné dans mars attacks waart
studio flore donc ça c'est les tâches de
son studio d'art un vraiment de l'art là
c'est quoi cet endroit attend le mec
mais juste tu n'as pas le droit de te
plaint de quoi bien sûr que ta vision
orientée il faut pas être un génie pour
leurs marques et william à sa cuisine
voilà qu'est ce qu'il ya dans la cuisine
bordel dans mais à écouter alors voilà
on inspecte une maison pas ouvert et
fils micro ondes et tu antennes aulas
m'a trouvé on est à la phase on peut
faire les malins
qu'est-ce qu'il fait autant de bruit
c'est ce frigo mais qu'il faut tempérer
plus tard mais change de frigo tout de
suite quoi a le téléphone il est ou allô
allô allô en est pas tenu là s'il vous
plaît quoi champlain inspection d'une
maison alors faites pas chier à l'ask et
un étage suppose qu'il ya un endroit
pour aller en aussi un endroit pour
monter dans cet art voilà l'endroit pour
moi j'y arrive pas du tout et nous met
dans l'ambiance d'inspection des maisons
effrayés
moi je fais la fête il a des caméras et
tout mais carrément [ __ ] il croit
vraiment à son délire de maisons 21
alors à vous entendez après le canular
téléphonique c'est le canular portique à
ok de faut que je trouve un lit pour
dormir voilà on se réveillera demain il
est où ton [ __ ] de vie l'aï les bâtons
mec mes mecs mais mec juste on ne se
plaint pas on regarde ce que tu fais mon
gars tu fais le truc avec les led quoi
je suis pas grosse appel mais c'est
extrêmement effrayant on ferme la porte
s'il vous plaît prenez au papier juste
là bas que j'ai lus en gros son mari
s'est suicidé voilà et ils étaient
donnés tous un peu bizarre il a fini par
se suicider et lui se dit pourquoi on
peut dormir
1 j'ai eu le réflexe foetus quoi ah oui
ok donc faut dormir pour recharger la
caméra c'est pas trop fourbe a du coup
voilà la caméra de surveillance on a une
vie
on de ce qui se passe un peu et ils se
posent oui effectivement effectivement
les 68 bizarre effectivement c'est là
qu'elles nous font un petit podcast la
meuf j'ai pas si vous avez remarqué mais
ce sont les maisons et tout on se
réveille on se répond nous en rêvent
mais qu il rêve
il est en train de rêver waouh qu'est ce
qui se passe avec quel est le foot au
tas mais arrêtez toqués partout dans
cette maison bordel commençais à
m'ennuyer
et on se couche pas et des bougies
allumées [ __ ] c'est dangereux non mais
faut l'éduquer ce mec faut tout lui
apprendre sans déconner c'est
insupportable on s'en va pas ici
ok on prend un bon jab sur eux ça marche
pas on verra jamais cet homme nu et
c'est une bonne chose
alors là s'il ya quelqu'un qui est dans
ma maison mon gars je me fâche est très
fort pourquoi je les sors je ne dois te
comprend une bougie on le brûle on le
brûle on peut pas prendre le bouchon le
pousse gentiment dans les escaliers puis
il se fait un petit torticolis j'ai
entendu des bruits non y'a marqué non
vous avez quelque chose pantin oui je
suis un homme bizarre je parle à mes
sculptures vous avez quelque chose ou
pas [ __ ] haut
qu'est-ce qui se passe une grande à
cowes c'est quoi ce bordel
j'vais h puis je me suis pris une petite
balayette par quelqu'un qui passait par
là c'est vous pratiquez le kung-fu
marionnettes
alors on revient dans la cuisine voilà
est-ce que le frigo futur du bruit
puisqu'il fait plus de bruit en mon dieu
un couteau a été déplacé oui fait
toujours du bruit donc logiquement tout
va bien tout va extrêmement bien voilà
on peut toujours pas reprendre de bière
ça non pourra jamais pour le mans a donc
le petit fantôme s'est quand même fait
un petit encas voilà je me disais bien
qui est un petit peu maigre attention
par contre va se retrouver ça devient
fois la débrouille chez moi jumbo tu
arrêtes de te mettre bien avec nous n'a
la maison est hantée regardez regardez
oui et alors faut aller en bas ah ok ça
fait un bruit de pistolet laser quand tu
touches cette poignée s'est fermé en bas
et à l'étagé se passer un truc ici
toujours rien non que dalle c'est quoi
ce bruit via la radio c'est la télé
c'est là où la mauvaise idée o la
voiture comment est ce tu as encore un
petit papier car amendée qui raconte des
choses étranges
c'est la radio la voiture qu'ils
allumaient d'ide ont tué l'amour de ma
vie dans son assaut ensemble sait pas
trop comment je vais pouvoir faire vu
qu'il n'ya que le haut du corps mais il
ya l'important les yeux l'issue d'une
femme ça vaut tout l'or du fonds à la
plus beaux coups de batte il en a deux
barres sur 5 500 l'extinction ça sent le
dodo comme on dit le dodo le dodo loose
c'est en fait quoi attendez je vais
prendre un poisson je viens prendre un
[ __ ] de poisson mais semaine dans mes
veines c'est l'heure de dormir la laitue
mangent des poissons et un problème
qu'est-ce qui se passe
in the kitchen quelqu'un a planté un
coup dans le mur voit rien assis là y'a
un tabouret qui bouge tout seul dit donc
haut du dos et c'est pas le marionnettes
qui fait ça je vous le dis a commencé
par éteindre ça mais sans déconner alors
on est et rhône
qu'est ce qui sonne on y ont regardé un
peu je filme sa tournée vous voyez il ya
bien un boîtier pour arrêter ce [ __ ]
d'armes l'ariane endroit pour sa gueule
ah d'accord ok à nickel nickel ça fait
une fête sur moi ça prévient pas [ __ ]
à l'est du camp mais les gars sans
déconner tu ce qui vous est arrivé là
qu'est ce qui vous prend aux eaux au med
d'accord d'accord ça prend des fois non
sans prévenir
si je comprends bien c'est ça nickel non
mais non pour les tops pour les tarn et
un toit avec toi séoul a plus rien le
mec il filme pour sa [ __ ] de vidéo
mais parfois en courant de la maison
quoi ah non non non il veut faire son
million de vues il veut le faire
j'arrive téléphone parce que c'est un
téléphone une tondeuse à cheveux là à
l'accord bouteille de vin non mais
attendez mais c'est bien comme il faut
cette histoire alors elle a fait la
table elle m'a servi le petit vin elle
m'appelle
[Applaudissements]
ah ouais ok d'accord d'accord c'est pas
gagné ok non mais là il est en tout cas
secondes je déteste ça l'écrit comme ça
nul ou au non non non mais mais une fois
la fête sans moi ils volent tout ce
qu'il ya dans mon frigo dans mais ça
suffit ok on va établir des règles dans
cette maison premièrement quand tu tires
du [ __ ] de 20 tu ranges ton [ __ ] de
20 mhz et accroche pas isabelle au mur
comme c'est bien mais quel téléphone
crise à calais phoque est tous blessés à
capri tout ce qu'il y avait dans le
frigo [ __ ] mais sans déconner ce jeu
est vraiment drôle
on savait où vacances à un pardon ça
passe tellement amusant à isabelle a
disparu voilà c'est bien vous avez rangé
sa belle maintenant vous allez ranger ce
foutoir par terre à papa squeeze ou pas
papou souidi on l'appelle dans le milieu
vous avez quand même pas fait la fête au
grenier bon alors là là c'est la sacrée
punition en fait attention à ce que vous
avez fait là où c'est bien les enfants
c'est bien rien alors oh [ __ ] mais lui
aussi souhaité tout temps ça ça m'énerve
toujours fermé cette porte vers le bas
pour arthur tu surveilles alexis
attendez on peut aller là bas ou pas ce
soit on peut sortir pour s'enfuir en
courant
mais oui au regard des [ __ ] on s'en
fout on se tire on s'en va on sait vous
attend non mais non mr pussycat ou non
mais les gars à l'égard à la vertu
recevait dans son jardin mais un portail
qui fait 8 mètre vingt de santé ce
qu'ils puissent pay to s'enfuir alors
qui sait qu'il a une [ __ ] de maison
hantée locaux donc ça sauve avec son
mari qui s'est suicidé comme je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure il hantait dans son
[ __ ] de jardin nickel moi un ami meurt
j'enterre dans mon jardin bien sûr ses
preuves est normal à ya eu un petit
message en fait
en fait le fantôme c'est lui un chien
maintenant mais où mais c'est quoi ce
bordel
ouais ok on se marre on se barre on se
bat et des mailles du sens là vous avez
vu très glauque
alors je serais toi je condamnerai cette
fenêtre et je veux construire un mur par
dessus suivi d'un mur en acier trempé
suivi d'une feuille a4
voilà la feuille a4 c'est juste au cas
où s'il veut mettre ses mains pleines de
sang dans nos races et emprunte à elle
retrouvera j'ai fait un stage auprès de
l'inspecteur gordon à ya une porte qui
s'ouvre
la petite vidéo avec moi c'est ça tu
sembles avoir un bain de sang au moment
où wall ou une toilette de sang j'ai un
chien je n'avais pas cher un chien mais
c'est aussi ces choses à préciser ça
peut être un coupable de plus alors on
s'endort et ce qu'on fait un rêve
vraiment l espace quoi à ckoi
c'est un pantin c'est un pantin oui il
est là il fait rien et l'attend on se
réveille le 3 juillet avec notre chien
qui n'a pas bougé du tour dont tu slip
ne dort pas pour info c'est moi le chef
de cette [ __ ] de maison c'est moi qui
fixe les règles a dit oui un petit un
petit vent un petit à petit ventoux à il
est toujours là le pantin du coup aller
si j'ai demandé à partir de surveiller
bordel viens avec moi vient d'en moi
même si tu veux voilà aucun problème
alors on va voir ce que les enfants fou
en bas un maman et temps on peut pas se
barrer par là pour aller montrer au
monde entier ce qu'on vient de filmer
non non il il attend de mourir à cause
du fantôme en fait qui est ami ça oh oh
ah oui michel aulas je crois savoir un
peu peur quand même ça suffit les
conneries maintenant je sais que j'ai
pas d'autorité donc malheureusement je
pourrais jamais faire régner l'ordre le
téléphone sonne et je réponds et ça fait
rien elle a fait les courses plus tard
et respectueux le fantôme quand même
maman le vin toujours pas ranger bon
jeune homme jeune homme tout ça dans mon
petit quart d'heure visite quoi tu juste
là à lui s'est mis devant la porte ni
qu'elle n'est pas grande halle fin si je
veux passer je passe bombe a peut-être
finalement tué gandalf mémé tu vas bien
changé gandalf ok on va aller dans cette
pièce on va monter là haut ah non paris
puis en appel au coin du bar et je la
perds point de la lampe dans ton cul
s'est passé quoi s'est passé quoi il
s'est passé quoi je suis mort c'est ça
j'suis marque ce que j'ai voulu faire un
bisou sur le fond d'importance et ça et
comment je montre au monde ce que j'ai
filmé mois comme la vôtre
[ __ ] et puis tout s'est cependant
falloir gérer c'est là qu'ils sourient
perdre à l'éduquer en plus de ça il ya
un bruit bizarre je vous jure qu'il ya
un bruit bizarre
boureima l'agencé d'air france et des
dom j'espère ça ne va plus et ces cas
n'hésitez pas à aller mais comme
d'habitude suis content d'avoir fait le
jeu ça fait un bail que je l'avais vue
et puis en fait le principe est juste
trop marrant côté dans une maison il se
passe plein de trucs bizarres et puis tu
filmes voilà jusqu'à ta propre mort
c'est quand même fort ce soir c'est le
nouvel an passé un bon nouvel an ce qui
vous le disais en gage des choix bien
sûr merci à me regarder on se retrouve
très vite dans une nouvelle vidéo tient
tout le monde dise
[Musique]
rires